so we don't we actually interviewed uh
Jason how anis and he release the piece
talking about and how you know you to
monetize on you to might not be
investing your you're always constantly
dropping videos about the meet no post
how do you use those things to monetize
on your hustle since those things like
maybe belong to you or you can't do that
email collection and this is where
people are confused I am thrilled to do
anything anywhere if it's bringing me
awareness to convert later down the line
the biggest problem right now in the
game is that everybody wants last point
of distribution attribution to their
sale what this talk do for me my man
like it did the books that I got 100
bucks
it's me giving you love because I like
you right in your crew it's forty people
you're gonna know a little bit more for
the next time it's the eleven people
that didn't know me at all
and so I'm not worried about I'm worried
about what this specific hour on Friday
night where my wife was like what are
you doing
like I thought you're gonna be a hoarder
look at Friday so it's going to do for
me this moment I'm worried about what
it's going to do for me long-term the
reason that right now the media is I
read the piece on medium it will go
viral and then everybody that goes to
medium calm they see one of the top 10
most you know read articles that day and
there's a lot of people going to medium
calm that have never heard of me like
all of them like 99% of people still
don't know who I am
so these are my right for media and the
reason I write for lengthens influencer
program is when I get something that
goes viral
they have triggers that allow people who
never heard of me if you write one of
the five top articles on LinkedIn if
you've read it some of the length in
articles you see on the right side then
they show the top five articles that day
that allowed me to reach people that
have never heard of me so the reason I
do things like YouTube when oh I hope
everybody's on it and I can be
discovered you do things I mean it's
crazy to think only one chess move
nobody here really lives their lives
like everything you do at that moment
what's the ROI of that I understand that
I can't comfort on my website at that
moment but if you build like I'm just
trying to fry bigger fish if I'm trying
to build a big enough brand I could pay
seventy thousand dollars to get Y our
keynote I would never get that if I was
worrying about selling like $4 ebooks on
my [ __ ] domain page
so so I'm just playing a long game I
think we're all a lot younger you know I
mean like I don't know like who here is
retiring in the next ten years I don't
mean I don't mean you do gonna [ __ ]
kill it and retire
one family who I don't believe so one
gentleman I believe that one gentleman
but the rest of us are all planning on
winding is working a decade from now do
you want the whole look like ten years
ago like we weren't even fully like a
plated cellphone that out yet
let alone smart let alone social there
was no Facebook there was no YouTube
that exists so I think long term I think
really long term I'm not worried about
tomorrow you know and so I mean so many
of my decisions on that which is why
it's confusing to most but I just want
to let the card to play out the way they
do it why they do a lot of stuff like
this to document it to for the next
generation see that you can also win by
running the marathon you don't need to
sell Instagram for a billion dollars
five hundred days in everybody's trying
to chase that one-in-a-trillion there's
just such a guaranteed way to put in the
work and you bring in quality and you
keep doing it and you grind and you
hustle day in and day out that's how
many more people win and succeed that
the one offs that happen once in a
generation